[Music]
[Music]
mr. Logan
Jesus please we need a ride not
available call a cab
my name is W I want to know your name
lady there are men after us I need to
get out of here
go north girls to Canada anyone can do
that job I'll give you $50,000 how did
you find me huh you're [ __ ] up my life
lady people after you they're on my ass
now sightings were posted Laura what
going what sightings people said someone
look like The Wolverine was in an paso
driving said he looked old hey I told
you to stop it with that phone Oh dad
please
I do bad girls so they're gonna have to
pay for damages and she has cash I seen
it
she gets you a feather speck in your
office you'll get your money
[Music]
I'm a nurse
was a Mexico City
did that happen this morning near the
bar I got away from that one now they
know my God look I gotta go
oh wait wait please yeah here please
right look look yeah did this $20,000
here take us to these others you can
have 30,000 more when we get there
my friends same with Garrity they won't
be waiting
yeah we'll give you anything where'd you
get this
my boyfriend he wants to kill me and
take her that's your daughter
yes
I know you're still good inside I know
you want to help us you don't know
anything about me please I promise there
will be no problems if we leave now I
can't just leave to North Dakota have to
be there Friday or what oh we miss our
chance to cross please
you have to please please
I like those they make you look younger
Charles's I gotta go but it go away for
a few days okay I have a long ride
there's some good money but when I get
back with me get out of here gonna drive
down your lap oh we're gonna get
ourselves a bowl then I go live on the
ocean will you be safe there
yeah yeah we'll be safe no what no one
got his chart
be back in a few days
[Music]
Logan what happened something the rope
job is wrong forgive
well done
no gun what good is this belong to
who's that but she was supposed to see
she coming I can track mutants I'm a
glorified truffled in a clairvoyant
on-site you Charles quiet don't sigh now
need to turn around [ __ ] this is
private property
yes it is in fact I believe it belongs
to a multinational smelting company
based in Shanghai where you keep me old
man hmm they're worried there I'd be
smart I'd like to meet him I'm told to
HSA classifies his brain as a weapon of
mass destruction now damn saying what
happened back east it's been dead for
years I need the girl what girl when it
goes along with that ball you up there's
no girl here I know you went to the
motel
it was cold there there was a girl it's
just a woman just one such as she was so
you saw Gabriella but you didn't call me
that hurts but you didn't shoot the poor
thing did you how did you I asked you
first
I don't like guns of course you should
call me Logan I got
see you're not the only ones been
enhanced Logan Logan this is Laura
Caliban come this is who I've been
telling you about this is Laura we've
been waiting for you hemos estando s
Esperanza 40 come come here it's okay
come Laura it's okay it's okay
come Beneke
come come it's okay you can stay here
Laura
come on
looks like ex-military bounty hunter
named worse is he by himself
enough along get him back before I take
him out to the wash and dump him what if
he wakes up before I get that takes me
where you are we'll pick you up
hello you know you gotta pay for that
right hey come on
not okay we got ourselves an x-men fan
maybe a quarter what happens
and not let this in the real world
people die Logan I don't want to talk
about it Logan
just stop be careful
I need the girl baccarat go-getter
[Music]
no no no and we're down oh she's like
you oh very much like you oh not
whatever it is you think I am now she
needs our help
someone come off someone has come along
well
this is what life looks like
people love each other
you should take a moment
cela
you still have time
[Music]
and